hello everyone the three days of rapid
in st. Louis are over and now we have
two days of blitz the first day of blitz
is also over today will be the last day
of the Blitz event and here we have a
nice game between Sharma media revenue
chuan at an island from the Blitz
section it's a very nice game before we
check it out we do have a photo
challenge taken in 1987 so best of luck
to everyone who is the gentleman on the
left and super extra points if you also
know the gentleman on the right so there
we have it and before we check it out we
do have a couple of photos here we have
a very nice photo of Mommy dr off
although it's from his game against
kurakin but nevertheless a very very
nice photo also a nice photo of island
here from the st. Louis rapid and blitz
and here we have something that we will
check out after we check out this game
so mommy here have had the white pieces
and he opened with Knight to f3 the reti
opening d5 we have III Knight to f6 c4
and c6 now nice to see three we have c5
c captures he captures and d4 now and
the knight to c6 transposing into the
tower defense the two knights variation
Bishop to b5 by momager of C capture son
d 4e capture son d4 and Bishop to d6
preparing to Castle rush up to g5 we
have a bush up to e6 and both players
Castle rook to e1 we have worked to c8
and now nice to e5 and here a very nice
position to you know decide what to do
here
here you can't get rid of the knight on
e6 if you capture then white captures
back you lose a piece here if you
capture with the bishop still doesn't
help you d captures and even if you
don't lose a piece here because you can
go h6 but after this you can then move
the knight or you can simply simply
capture here and after captures you will
get this rook captures on e6 where you
have to capture the rook and then queen
g4 will be crushing TF 7 check your move
check Knight captures on d5 and black is
completely busted here if you capture
with the Queen Queen e7 is checkmate the
knight on c6 is pinned and of course if
you capture with the pawn then
rook to e1 check you have to block and
the Queen captures on e7 the same
checkmate
so after 95 better get rid of this
Bishop pinning the knight on f6 we have
h6 Bishop to h4 and now g5 Bishop to g3
and now we're on and does have this
option of capturing the night he decides
to go for a different approach he
doesn't want to give up his Bishop air
too early he goes Knight to e7 and here
he is preparing Knight to a5 to attack
my Medea I was Bishop and g3 but this
allows the media off for a wonderful
move really a game-changer in this game
he plays Knight to d7 it's a wonderful
idea because the Queen is now no longer
guarding the bishop on d6 but also the
knight on f6 that is unprotected is
attacked knife captures on f6 is a
threat also Knight captures and I faith
is a threat so we have to take care of
this Knight Bishop captures was played
and we have Bishop captures on d6 a
winning the piece back rook to e8 you
don't have time to capture here because
you get a Bishop captures on e7 with an
attack on the Queen and the rook so look
to e8 first
and now Queen to f3 again attacking the
knight here while you can play something
like Knight to c6
it's not an easy move to make in a blitz
game for example but for captures Bishop
captures rook captures Bishop captures
and here black would actually be okay
White's bishop is under attack Bishop
has to move and now the game continues
white white would still have a small
advantage but you know it's a blitz game
so nice to f5 was played by Anand and
here a very nice move Bishop to e5 and
here you have a position where Anand is
in a lot of trouble
the knight on f5 is attacked and also
the knight on f6 is an attack both of
these Knights are defended at the moment
but Bishop captures only 7 is a threat
which would force the Queen to recapture
and then the knight on f6 was would no
longer be guard also Bishop captures
would remove the Queen from defending
the bishop so a lot of things to
consider here the best line black could
go for is rook captures on c3 and after
B captures capture on b5 then comes
captures and f6 captures and after
captures captures
it seems like you have two pieces for
the rook but that's not really the case
because here mom Dara would have this g4
move and he would win this night so it
would be a Queen and the rook against
the Queen and a bishop with most likely
a winning game for white but it were to
give a black the most chances here are
none played in nice to e4 and this
allows mama DRF to really finish the
game in a beautiful fashion Bishop
captures on d7 was played Queen captures
on d7 and now Knight captures on d5 and
it was in this position and move 20 that
Vishwanathan Anand world rapid chess
champion resigned the game and former
world classical chess champion of course
but yeah there's nothing really to do
here
this Knight is attacked twice this
Knight is attacked if you capture here
and there really isn't a better move for
example if you capture Queen captures
here the knight is attacked twice
there's no good way to defend it if you
move the knight and IDC then you get
Queen to f8 and there is no preventing
checkmate on g7 you could give up the
exchange here but it wouldn't help you
all that much the Queen will simply
gobble up all the points here it's a
completely lost position you cannot
capture because of rook captures with
check he was the queen so a very nice
miniature xx move miniature by chakra
mama D are really the powerhouse from
Beale continues his onslaught here as
you can see I mentioned we're gonna
check it out so these are the combined
standings of the Blitz and rapid section
after three days of rapid and one day
blitz so it's soccer mom in Europe in
first place tied with Hikaru Nakamura in
second with 17 points then Caruana
who had an excellent start to the
tournament but that that rook blunder
against the living is really costing a
lot there then in fourth Maxima Sheila
Grove Levon Aronian Sergei Kirk in
linear Dominguez Alexander Grisha cuesta
so and in last place
Vishwanath on Anand so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it it's a very short
game but later for today I have game 5
planned of the favorite amount of series
which will be an over 20 minute video so
you know now a short one and then for
later you will be able to enjoy more
chess so as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
we'll see you soon